so today we're talking about the
september nintendo direct again how the
multiplayer beta for halo was almost
delayed and if you can expect another
titanfall anytime soon my name is
davonte chisholm and you're watching
game spot news
first off let's start with what leaked
before the show instead of outside
sources releasing information about
today's announcements early the leak
came from nintendo itself with the
company's japanese release schedule site
listing a new kirby game along with
other long-awaited titles including
bayonetta 3. during the actual show we
learned that both of those announcements
were real with kirby coming in spring
2022 and bayonetta coming sometime next
year as well towards the middle of the
show we learned that the final smash
bros character reveal is getting its own
direct on october 5th at 7 00 am pt 10
am et after that nintendo revealed an
expansion pack for nintendo switch
online that includes n64 and sega
genesis games and controllers to go
along with it the price of the
controllers were said to be 50
but the price of the new online
expansion was not revealed the service
will launch later this year with a
selection of solid games and more to
come down the line later on we got to
see the cast of the new animated mario
feature film for the first time this
lineup includes chris pratt as mario
anya taylor joy as peach charlie day as
luigi jack black as bowser keegan
michael key as toad and seth rogen as
donkey kong
moving right along to some halo news on
september 22nd 343 industries discovered
some late breaking issues with the halo
infinite multiplayer and the studio
nearly delayed the upcoming beta during
the halo infinite multiplayer live
stream on wednesday 343's brian jarrett
said that there might be a small shift
in the schedule for halo's next
multiplayer beta luckily the plan to
launch the beta client thursday
september 23rd seems to still be in
effect 343 industries even posted a new
blog of beta details and brian tweeted
the post and said quote we are preparing
for takeoff so have you gotten your
email yet let me know in the comments
and before we continue let's talk about
refrigerators because aaron greenberg
who is in charge of xbox games marketing
said that more information about the
xbox series x mini fridge will be
revealed next month if you didn't know
this all started when greenberg promised
that if xbox won twitter's best of
tweets brand bracket back in april then
xbox would go ahead and make the fridges
well xbox just barely beat out skittles
in the contest by one percent and thus
greenberg made good on his promise
it's weird to me that i don't want an
xbox series x but i really want this
fridge like i just picture it like right
where you are like just over a tiny bit
like i feel like it would look good
right there
anyway
moving on to some titanfall news
yesterday news outlets picked up a
comment from respawn community
coordinator jason garza who said that
the company was working on too many
games to focus on titanfall right now
when asked by fans about the possibility
of a new titanfall he said quote there's
nothing there's nothing there however
garza did say that respawn was working
on the ddos attacks plaguing titanfall 1
and 2. after the story was picked up by
numerous gaming news outlets respawn
issued an official statement on twitter
and said quote contrary to what some
folks are reporting titanfall is the
very core of our dna who knows what the
future holds
do we really need a titanfall 3
obviously the answer is yes i really
want to titanfall 3. but i'm curious
what you think so let me know in the
comments below and while you're there if
you watch the nintendo direct let me
know what your favorite announcement was
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you